with Tucker they're going to keep him on
the payroll
for a for a while until a couple of
things happen one is that he signs the
non-disclosure agreement
so he won't be dumping on Fox when he
leaves okay that's one of the things
they'd like to get and in the meantime
they're going to use the leak machine to
degrade his brand so that his his
options will be less whatever they are
now they'll be less by the time he gets
out and if you don't believe me just
look at the Lou Dobbs model that's what
they did with Lou Lou was the Tucker of
Fox Business what they did with Lou now
he was a sacrificial lamb they fired him
they kept him on the payroll I think it
was for over a year
and now he's you know he's doing a
podcast and he you know he's I love Lou
but he's you know struggling to stay in
the top 100